bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 27 mai
nouvelle édition de votre journal de fin
de semaine merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv fil 78
voici les sujets que nous allons aborder
au cours de la prochaine demi heure le
numérique au coeur des débats à
l'occasion de son assemblée générale
annuelle la fédération yvelinoise de la
ligue de l'enseignement organisé hier
soir à une table ronde sur ce thème et
ses enjeux dans le monde de l'éducation
mais aussi professionnels l'antenne
locale versaillaise de l'association ufc
que choisir fête ses 40 ans à cette
occasion elle organise les différentes
initiatives
explications avec philippe fleuret son
président il est notre invité
aujourd'hui dans ce journal
et comme chaque vendredi le zapping de
l'information locale depuis lundi avec
la mobilisation contre la loi travail la
pénurie de carburant en france et le
blocage de la station de dépôt de
coignières par la cgt chez nous
reviendrons également sur les
initiatives du département concernant le
très haut débit et la décision de la
région ile-de-france de faire des tests
de dépistage du cannabis chez les
lycéens et le 1er janvier 2016 jacques
l'oeil aux maires honoraires de magny
les hameaux a été promu chevalier de la
légion d'honneur à l initiative du
préfet des yvelines
il a été décoré hier par catherine tasca
vice présidente du sénat pour la
reconnaissance de 55 années de service
pour ses concitoyens dans le cadre de
différentes missions en présence de
bertrand lyon la cérémonie ait lieu à
magny les hameaux à la dément à la
demande de l'ancien maire à qui nous
avons demandé ce qu'il contenait de ses
57 y avait des services écouter voilà la
surprise c'était un sécuriser leurs
patients ou arrêtez donc comment je les
su s'est amené voisins qui le doivent
consister avait eu le journal officiel
et qui est venu frapper à ma porte pour
me dire en des dons c'est formidable ce
qui vous arrive ce qui était reconnue
c'est donc le début de mon combat donc
sur le temps public donc quand j'avais
18 ans quand j'ai refusé partir en
algérie
quand je me suis engagé donc j'ai
dénoncé la peine
partenaires et ses ponts de paris
j'étais reconnu j'ai été engagé en trois
ans et puis donc là j'ai découvert un
métier fabuleux
il ya des choses sur lesquelles je suis
encore donc bien ciblées sur des choses
qui sont donc pour moi très importante
qui est donc pour moi l'hôpital de jour
de joie handicap et ce serait donc pour
moi dans un tri morales peut
effectivement donc cette structure qui
est magique qui a fait ses preuves
depuis 2010 ne puisse pas donc vivre et
politiques à présent hier soir à
versailles l'association initiative 78
organisé son sixième débat le thème
portait sur le revenu universel en
revenus pour tous quelle que soit sa
situation une mesure déjà testé dans
certains pays du nord de l'europe
frédéric lefebvre candidat à la primaire
de la droite et benoît hamon conseiller
régional d'île de france étaient
présents pour partager leurs idées sur
ce sujet camille lambert pour ce
reportage
un revenu pour tous distribués tout au
long de sa vie sans contrepartie c'est
l'idée du revenu universel
jeudi 26 mai l'association initiative 78
organisé un débat sur le sujet une
soixantaine de curieux ont fait le
déplacement pour assister à cet échange
et c'est l'occasion pour nous de pouvoir
rassembler tout le monde autour d'une
table autour d'un repas convivial et de
débattre de sujets qui pourrait on va
dire être effectué au sein de
l'assemblée nationale ou dans toute
autre instance et là on les aborde
sereinement les mains avec comme je le
disais tout à l'heure des personnalités
de mort totalement différents mais qui
sont là aujourd'hui justement pour
débattre et construire ensemble
frédéric lefebvre candidat à la primaire
de la droite et benoît hamon conseiller
régional ile-de-france du parti
socialiste ont partagé leur avis une
première pour benoît hamon qui ne
s'était pas encore réellement exprimés
sur le sujet voit dans ce domaine ma
religion est pas tout à fait
ce qui est clair c'est que si je devais
me prononce en faveur d'un revenu
d'existence ce serait pour qu'il
relativise la place qui est celle de
travail aujourd'hui dans nos vies ce que
je pense que il a pris une place
démesurée au point qu'on en juge qu'on
ne puisse s'épanouir que par le travail
je pense que fort heureusement à
s'épanouir 2000 autre manière qu'on
travaille en est le revenu d'existence
peut peut-être écouté les rapports nous
disent que dans les dix ans on va
détruire trois millions d'emplois de
plus il travaille va va muter on est en
pleine mutation est donc le seul moyen
aujourd'hui de s'adapter à la réalité de
l'époque c'est de changer de modèle et
le modèle que je défends c'est le revenu
universel qualifié d'utopistes par ses
détracteurs le revenu universel fait
pourtant son chemin dans plusieurs pays
la finlande est prête à tenter
l'expérience avec un montant
inconditionnels de 800 euros par citoyen
selon l'insee en france plus de 8
millions de personnes vivent en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté
et parlons d'éducation à présent à
l'occasion de son assemblée générale
annuelle la ligue
la fédération yvelinoise de la ligue de
l'enseignement organisé une table ronde
sur le thème du numérique les adhérents
partenaires et acteurs de la ligue
contentieux et échanger sur l'évolution
du numérique au sein de l'éducation mais
aussi du monde du travail
mélanie pompiers étaient sur place hier
soir regardez se former au et par le
numérique à l'école en famille où
travaille la fédération des yvelines de
la ligue de l'enseignement invité hier
partenaires et acteurs locaux pour
échanger sur les enjeux du numérique
le numérique c'est incontestablement une
révolution une révolution à la fois dans
les conditions de travail une révolution
à la fois dans les les potentiels de
développement nous sommes un territoire
qui est relativement bien placé sur le
numérique
et puis pour nous c'est une
diversification qu'on est en train de
réussir
nous avons obtenu le label de la grande
école de numérique pour une formation
que l'on va développer à partir de la
rentrée prochaine sur ce territoire qui
est une formation de développeurs
d'applis web milieu particulièrement
concernés l'école où se multiplient
notamment tablettes et tableaux
numériques
la ligue est en partenariat avec le
rectorat de versailles et une dizaine de
collectivités des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine pour un projet ifrane on
voit que de nombreuses mairies aussi
accompagnent ces projets puisque tout ça
c'est de la co construction et c'est
tout l'intérêt de socialiser et puis
d'avancer ensemble à partir d'un projet
souvent qui est citoyen et pour la
réussite des élèves pour que demain ils
trouvent un emploi ou une place dans la
vie et que la fracture numérique soit
pas encore une cause d'échec scolaire
la ligue organisme d'action sociale et
de formation professionnelle travaillent
en collaboration avec 390 associations
sur le territoire des yvelines bonjour
vous êtes le président de l'antenne
versaillaise de l'ufc que choisir qui
représente donc les ive et noie dans la
commission des usagers notamment ainsi
qu'au sein de la commission
départementale d'aménagement commercial
vous fêté cette année ses 40 ans à
versailles
et pour cela vous organiser différentes
initiatives alors certaines sont déjà
passés l'une à vue le 25 mai et bientôt
le 6 et le 4 juin
oui donc le 4 jeunes seront présents sur
le marché de montigny samedi prochain 2
entre 9h et 12h donc durant leur
rencontre des consommateurs
et puis le 6 e seront à la maison de
quartier louis jouvet à montigny à 19h30
pour une conférence oui conversion à
plusieurs plusieurs thèmes d'ailleurs
donc on fera le point sur l'évolution de
l'association et puis nous
interviendrons sur la prévention des
hamacs à domicile et sur les réflexes en
matière d'alimentation les bons réflexes
vous fêtez donc vous car on tond 40 ans
d'existence et cette année est ce que
valait 1 40e rôle a évolué ce que
l'émission l'association ont changé oui
bien sûr que ça vous coupe évoluer parce
que en 40 ans la société française a
beaucoup évolué et les pratiques en
matière de consommation aussi
juste un exemple dans le domaine de la
téléphonie ou bon internet n'existait
pas il ya quarante ans le téléphone
c'était une administration
c'étaient les ptt et des dons qui avait
pas de litige pour ainsi dire et
aujourd'hui tout ça est maintenant dans
le champ concurrentiel et voilà donc
nous avons des litiges et justement avec
internet du coup les gens peuvent plus
se renseigner seuls ils font toujours
autant appel à vous de plus en plus
parce que les gens veulent s de bien
informer et donc de plus en plus une
font appel à nos services à travers les
comparateurs de prix les comparateurs
alors en 2015 vous avez traité 637
litige et + 2 vous avez également à
votre compte plus de 100 millions
restitués après ce litige
comment vous fonctionnez vous avez des
juristes bénévoles qui prennent le oui
nous avons servi city jô un autre
association avec toujours 2 juriste
stagiaire qui sont des futurs avocats
stagiaires généralement et donc nous
instruisons les dossiers nous nous
basons donc sur le code du commerce sur
le code des concurrents sur le code de
la consommation
pour trancher les litiges en faveur
généralement toujours des consommateurs
oui oui on peut nous contacter et donc
soit en venant au siège de l'association
saint capraise des gendarmes à
versailles
c'est ouvert tous les matins de 9h à 12h
et puis autrement par téléphone ou par
internet
et du coup c'est pour vraiment où les
toutes sortes de dossiers ce que sa part
longtemps général parfois vous traiter
des cas sur plusieurs années n'ont
généralement généralement on règle les
cas en un mois à peu près un mois et
demi alors il fait il y aura évidemment
des dossiers plus lourd plus compliqué
qui nécessiteront plusieurs mois
maintenant généralement ça va assez vite
alors au regard de l'actualité donc de
ces de cette semaine alors voilà on a
parlé beaucoup la pénurie de carburant
est ce que vous avez été sollicité ce
que des gens par exemple ont dénoncé des
mauvaises pratiques des stations essence
non on n'a pas eu de remontée sur ce
niveau là parce qu'on nous a signalé
c'est que des gens différer leur acte
d'achat et donc qu'ils hésitaient à
prendre leur véhicule donc en attendant
de pouvoir circuler
est-ce que vous avez des conseils
peut-être à donner justement aux
consommateurs par rapport à cette
situation
ceux des conseils sont toujours les
mêmes c'est consommer généralement le
plus près de son domicile
sauf lorsqu'on utilise internet bien sûr
me retrouvant ses
au niveau local les gros sujets
d'actualité en ce moment qui est ce que
vous pensez des alertes particulièrement
sur la consommation sur l'alimentation
et qu'elle soit vous oui on est au
niveau de l'alimentation donc nous
organisons des ateliers avec en
partenariat avec les communes dont nous
en avons déjà fait à montigné à la
maison de quartier louis jouvet et donc
le but c'est d'informer les
consommateurs sur les équilibres des
produits et puis aussi désormais s'il ya
des produits nocifs tels le parabène ou
d'autres produits voilà c'est de
l'information
c'était la prévention s'il ya des
thématiques spécifiques dans les
yvelines par exemple sur ce sujet sur
l'alimentation ou les augmentations et
alors ça ça c'est sûr ddtm qui rencontre
un grand succès et peut également nous
intervenons dans toutes sortes de
domaines et notamment par exemple la
prévention des armes ak domicile parce
qu'on constate toujours çà et là des
personnels délicate souvent des artisans
qui profitent de la naïveté des gens
pour les arnaquer est ce qu'avec le
temps vous constatez que les
consommateurs sont de plus en plus
vigilants oui concédant plusieurs
évolutions déjà donc une nécessité un
besoin de transparence les gens veulent
être avoir une information sincère sur
la nature des produits la composition
des produits leur origine il veut
pouvoir comparaître et comparer faire
des comparaisons entre entre les
produits et donc ils sont plus exigeants
et sur quels sujets de voulait plus un
tel le plus interrogés politique le plus
alors ces derniers temps nous aurait été
intérieures jai
surtout dans le domaine de l'immobilier
parce que bon il ya eu un changement
doit une charge mais la loi allure et
donc chaque fois qu'un changement de
réglementation il ya toujours eu envie
un besoin d'adaptation de la part des
consommateurs immobilier téléphonie
voilà les grands sujets par rapport
justement à ces 40 années d'existence
cet anniversaire donc il a une
conférence qui a eu donc le 25 mai une
conférence le 6 juin qu'elle allait
faire d'autres initiatives organisées
d'autres choses au cours de l'année oui
il y en aura d'autres parce que donc les
communes de la région de houille dans le
nord-est département vont être rattaché
à notre attention local est dommage oui
oui oui et donc de frauder intervention
là bas dans ces communes la rechercher
d'autres bénévoles pour toujours
toujours toujours parce que vous savez
comme dit l'adage l'union fait la force
et donc plus les consommateurs seront
nombreux puits pour mieux se défendre
il ya des profils spécifiques que vous
recherchez fois la bénévole juristes
économistes en particulier très bien et
bien merci beaucoup philippe fleuret je
le rappelle le lundi 6 juin donc l ufc
que choisir l'antenne de versace une
conférence à 19h30 à montcy le
bretonneux la maison de quartier louis
jouvet n'hésitez pas à venir participer
si vous voulez plus d'information
regarder l'affiché le site internet
s'affiche en bas de votre écran merci à
doucement et dans notre journal d'hier
vous avez eu l'occasion de découvrir le
laboratoire du cnc le centre national du
cinéma dans ce service est dédié à la
restauration des films vous avez pu voir
les méthodes employées pour nettoyer une
pellicule mais la restauration ne
s'arrête pas à la phase analogique une
restauration numérique est souvent
nécessaire pour certains films plus
poussée elle permet de travailler
certains détails impossibles à corriger
en photochimie voici le dernier volet de
notre série consacrée au cnc de bois
d'arcy réalisé par william el est
guillaume le squer c'est l'une des deux
filières du laboratoire des archives du
cnc certains films ne passe pas
seulement par la restauration
photochimique mais sont aussi traités de
manière numérique et c'est sur ce
scanner que la pellicule va d'abord
passer pour être numérisés la bobine
original une fois qu'elle a été restauré
mécaniquement lorsqu'on a pu réparer les
coups des co lui ont des défauts sur le
film va être chargé sur sept ce scanner
qui va finalement faire une photo de
chaque image du film en très haute
qualité
là ce qu'on appelle un scanner 4k donc
on a plus de 4000 pixels de large sur
sur l'image chaque photo ça va être
transformée en une image informatique
donc on va avoir énormément de suite
d'image on peut avoir à peu près quinze
mille images pour l bobines de 300 m
dure à peine dix minutes une
numérisation en vue d'une restauration
dite de prestige retirait des défauts
comme les poêles ou les poussières qui
ne peuvent être enlevés autrement le
fichier passe alors dans un logiciel
dédié sont des logiciels vraiment très
spécifiques
dont les tous les outils
sont adaptés vraiment aux films anciens
c'est à dire qu'ils vont permettre de
corriger les défauts typiques des films
anciens c'est à dire les poussières le
manque de stabilité et des formations
d'image les rayures et nous notre rôle
c'est effectivement de retirer ses
défauts qui ont pu être causé par le
temps retiré des défauts dus au temps et
n'ont dû à la technique de l'époque un
travail extrêmement minutieux et surtout
très long car ici on travaille image par
image suivant suivant le
le nombre de défauts du film ça peut
être extrêmement long bon les outils ont
cette possibilité de travailler en
automatique et travaillent 24 heures sur
24 donc ça nous fait gagner du temps
mais le travail de l'opérateur est
nécessaire déjà pour contrôler les
restaurations qui sont faites par les
logiciels est effectivement ensuite
aller plus loin pour pour corriger des
défauts qui n'auraient pas pu être
retiré par le logiciel
en plus d'une restauration certains
films bénéficient d'un étalonnage d'une
opération réalisée pour des
restaurations plus de pousser qui
s'effectue dans l'obscurité la plus
totale
l'étalonnage est en fait une
harmonisation colorimétrique des plans
et des séquences pour retrouver une
cohérence visuelle sur la continuité du
film ici arnaud travail sur l'admirable
vision un film italien de 1920 dont une
partie des bobines a été retrouvé en
france et l'autre en italie tous les
films ne subissent pas le même degré
d'étalonnage effectivement sur un film
comme l'admirable vision
il ya un travail d'étalonnage
très important puisque une fois de plus
le film était dégradée donc il ya eu
tout un travail de recherches afin de
retrouver les couleurs d'origine
voilà tous les films ne sont pas
exploitées de la même manière tout
dépend des éléments que nous avons entre
nos mains
certains éléments
peuvent arriver chez nous en très bon
état et n'ont pas besoin d'un étalonnage
très poussée puisque la copie sera en
bon état contrairement à d'autres films
qui ont vraiment besoin d'un 90% du
travail d'étalonnage au cnc se fissure
des films de patrimoine autrement dit
les films les plus anciens une manière
de redonner une nouvelle vie au cinéma
d'antan et vous pouvez retrouver à cette
série de reportages réalisés par william
el est guillaume le squer sur notre site
internet est encore une fois un grand
merci à guillaume pour son implication
et son travail pendant deux mois au sein
de notre chaîne culture à présent
pendant trois mois trois poètes ont été
en résidence dans trois médiathèques et
saint-quentinoise leur résidence a pris
fin le week end dernier
à cette occasion ils ont chacun proposé
des rencontres afin de restituer leurs
travaux à voisins le bretonneux le
rhapsody yves godin proposer une
insurrection poétique avec était enfant
d'école de la commune qui l'a accompagné
en classe retour sur cette manifestation
avec mélanie poker fait pas de bruit ce
texte d'henri meschonnic et la terre
cool lance l'insurrection poétique de
voisins-le-bretonneux à l'origine de
l'idée ils gaudin poète et deezer est
inhérent d'abord le principe c'est de
donner la parole donné la parole à
celles et à ceux qui ne sont pas
forcément les plus loquaces c'est à dire
montrer que chaque être humain est là
pour grandir pour faire un pas devant
pour et en se libérant de cette façon-là
libère tous les autres qui sont autour
à la poésie elle va nous donner des
ailes
va nous donner de quoi de quoi encore
mieux grandir et puis entente des belles
choses peut-être caresser des oreilles
peut-être bercé ceux qui ont besoin
d'être bercé à un moment donné voilà les
acteurs de cette insurrection des élèves
de primaire de saint quentin en yvelines
dont deux classes vie sinoise ils ont
eux mêmes choisi les textes ont fait des
gestes en même temps pour ce pour anglet
ans européennes ont poussé et on en a
fait en anglais en arbitres et qu'on me
comprend et néo-zélandais ça nous a pris
un ou deux mois
petit à petit on les habille de mieux en
mieux en arriver à trouver après les
intonations basée sur l'écouté de
l'autre cette manifestation marque la
fin de la résidence dit gaudin
le poète a passé trois mois sur la
commune de voisins et les maintenant
temps de passer à votre rendez-vous
l'essentiel de l'actualité le résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
et comme chaque vendredi nous passons
maintenant à l'essentiel de l'actualité
le zapping des sujets développés dans ce
journal depuis lundi regardez en france
depuis dimanche les stations services
affichent des files interminables de
conducteurs venus faire le plein à magny
les hameaux cette station disposer
encore de quelques réserves ce matin
mais ne tiendra pas la journée c'est un
petit peu pénible dans le sens où on va
on va se retrouver en rupture de
différentes herbes urant en milieu voire
en fin d'après midi à cinq heures du
matin le dépôt de carburant de
coignières a été bloqué par une
cinquantaine de personnes
un site stratégique qui alimente en
essence les yvelines mais aussi
plusieurs départements d'île de france
un blocage organisé conjointement par
plusieurs syndicats
ça répond donc à l'appel qui a été lancé
par tous nos camarades dans les
raffineries a bien sûr amplifier le
mouvement et à généraliser les grèves
dans nos entreprises mais aussi à
soutenir et a multiplié les blocages des
dépôts en vue justement de construire le
rapport de force pour obtenir le retrait
de la loi travail chez les 700 taxis des
yvelines on est obligé de s'adapter amis
réservoir en objet de faire comme tous
les gens particulier d'aller garer resté
une demi heure de la revue dans le salon
services de son côté la fédération
française du bâtiment tire la sonnette
d'alarmé espère un dénouement rapide
alors je devrais revenir donc sur la
manifestation du 18 mai qu'on a vu cette
voiture incendiée ce policier blessé est
ce que ça reflète vraiment la station
des policiers en france aujourd'hui
c'est la relance parce qu'ils vivent au
jour le jour
oui tout à fait tout à fait et
d'ailleurs c'est des images et une vidéo
qui est qui et qui est parlante qui est
criante et qui montre tout à fait la
violence qui est exercée à l'encontre de
de mes collègues dans l'heure dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions c'est dans
ce bâtiment du chesnay que les
demandeurs d'asile devaient être
enregistrées en vue d'un accueil en
préfecture un projet désactiver vendredi
20 mai par le préfet les yvelines
en réponse aux inquiétudes des riverains
la plateforme d'accueil devait être
situé rue laurent gaudé à proximité
d'une école
ce qui a provoqué l'incompréhension des
parents d'élèves et de la mairie du
chéné la région ile de france qui adopte
et donc j'ai dit à 19 mai la proposition
portée par sa présidente valérie
pécresse des républicains de financer
des tests salivaires de dépistage de
drogue et des éthylotests pour une liste
des lycées en france et d'air afin de
lutter contre les addictions
c'est une décision dont parle beaucoup
en ce moment il fait polémique et elle
fait polémique et c'est normal ça je
veux bien le comprendre la drogue dans
le
lycée c'est un fléau et à pâques dans
les lycées d'ailleurs il ya dans les
collèges aussi c'est un fléau il faut
quand même savoir que ça
considérablement augmenté depuis trois
ans 30 % d'augmentation c'est quand même
important libre et indépendant c'est le
nom du nouveau groupe formé par cinq
élus de la majorité de la droite et du
centre à plaisir lors du dernier conseil
municipal à l'origine de cette scission
un vote celui de deux adjointes et d'un
conseiller municipal délégué qui se sont
opposés à la hausse des impôts locaux
lors de l'élaboration du nouveau budget
un choix que n'a pas apprécié la mère
joséphine coleman berger elle a donc
décidé de proposer qu'il soit démis de
leurs fonctions
le très haut débit pour tous d'ici 2020
c'est l'objectif que s'est donné le
conseil départemental des yvelines
vendredi 20 mai à versailles pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental et karl olive ont présenté
le syndicat mixte ouvert yvelines
numériques une structure publique créée
par le département qui permettra de
déployer le réseau très haut débit pour
le grand public comme l'expliquent son
vice-président alors plusieurs solutions
d'abord la possibilité d'être fibre est
très rapidement aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec un accompagnement de
l'état qui effectivement correspond
véritablement à quelque chose
d'important et qui nous permet de sortir
des emprunts toxiques montant de la
dette de la ville de plaisir 53 millions
d'euros
il lui reste aujourd'hui quatre emprunts
à rembourser pour un total de 38
millions d'euros
les taux sont fixés jusqu'en 2040 la
politique financière de la ville vise un
désendettement de 1.5 millions par an à
trappes
ils se sont confrontés à un texte de
victor hugo 93 lui est dicté par la
ministre de l'éducation et utiliser
cette opportunité pour finalement faire
revenir quand même
lève les jeunes leurs parents à
l'essentiel c'est à dire la bonne
maîtrise de la langue française
dix personnes sont repartis avec deux
places pour des matches de l'euro bien à
l'abri dans leur boîte
ici sur ses étagères ses pellicules sont
les témoins de l'histoire du cinéma
en tout ce sont plus d'un million de
bobines entreposés sur les deux sites du
cnc de bois d'arcy et du fort de saint
cyr un patrimoine inventorié restaurer
et conservé par le cnc et enfin moi à
présent des sujets que nous
développerons à partir de la semaine
prochaine à partir de lundi dans notre
journal nous reviendrons sur le conseil
d'agglomération qui s'est tenue ce jeudi
où il a notamment été question de projet
pour le territoire et qui a été quelque
peu mouvementée
également au programme l'euro 2016 avec
une série de reportages toute cette
semaine il sera question des bleus à
clairefontaine de l'équipe d'irlande est
à versailles ou encore de l'équipe de
russie qui elle est à croissy-sur-seine
et enfin un dernier rendez vous avant de
fermer ce journal dimanche à 18h vous
retrouver nicolas kirillovitch ce sur
radio sensations dans l'hebdo politique
dure soit robert et cadalbert l'ancien
président de saint quentin en yvelines
il évoquera sa nouvelle vie depuis qu'il
a quitté la politique
les critiques que sa présidence a essuyé
après son départ par la nouvelle
majorité de droite et enfin il confiera
son regard sur la politique actuelle
menée par son successeur michel logis à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je vous
propose d'écouter un extrait de
l'émission
ce qui est important c'est ce qui se
passe à saint quentin en yvelines
les politiques qui sont menées c'est
vrai qu'actuellement le président de
l'agglomération et c'est difficile pour
lui plus difficile pour moi parce que
les réductions d'aidés des dotations
je dis souvent si on n'avait pas changé
les règles du jeu il a vingt ans par les
les réformes de la taxe professionnelle
aujourd'hui on aurait pu rembourser
entièrement la dette de 50 on devine et
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis restez
avec nous dans un instant vos idées
sorties et loisirs avec mélanie poquet
aux commandes du 7-8 week-end
rendez-vous lundi à 18h vous en direct
pour le journal replay de nos reportages
et émissions sur le site internet de la
chaîne pouvez également nous suivre sur
les réseaux sociaux je vous retrouve
lundi
et vous souhaite un excellent week end